- Our next guest spent five seasons
as Jane's hotel owning baby
daddy and sometimes boyfriend
on the very popular
telenovela, "Jane the Virgin".
He's out now with a new book.
it's called "Man Enough
Undefining my Masculinity".
Please welcome Justin Baldoni.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat jazz music)
- Hi.
- I wish I could hug you.
- Aw.
- May I lead with the thing
that everyone leads with,
you are very talented
but your hair is just unbelievable.
Your unbelievable hair.
- Kelly Clarkson just gave me a.
- [Kelly] Have you done
a hair commercial yet?
This is the question I have.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh I've been, I've been
in at home by myself,
you know, with my family.
- [Kelly] Well.
- So this is exciting.
- [Kelly] Should've
made a hair commercial.
- Well, thank you.
(Kelly laughs)
Your hair is amazing.
- This is half mine.
- Also blue, I've tried to.
- We called each other.
I was like, you wear your
acid wash colors, but you are
you are doing well as
an actor and director.
So why write a book?
Did you always wanna write a book?
- No actually, I tried to get
out of this book a few times.
(audience and Kelly laughs)
And the irony is I wrote a
book called Man Enough Yet.
I think don't feel man
enough to have written it.
And for me, the book is
it's undefining masculinity.
It's taking men out
of this constricting box that
doesn't just hurt the women
and gender nonconforming,
and trans people.
But also, we hurt ourselves
and I didn't realize how
much I was suffering.
And so many men I know
are suffering, but we just
we can't ask for help.
We can't talk about it.
Cause we talk about it.
We're challenging the system
that keeps us in the box.
- Yeah.
- And we're hurting ourselves.
We're walking around miserable and unhappy
even though we're putting
on a face that we are.
So a book was, it was kind of
like a 2.0 of the Ted talk.
It was a way to put everything
on the page and it was
also really healing for me.
And it came out because I really believe
that the only way that we can heal is
if we can share our stories
so that other people can find their own.
And a lot of us men
are not comfortable
talking about these things.
- And it's a shame
because you're missing out
on all those extra layers of
the onion with men as well.
- Yeah.
- And they're missing out on it.
I heard your wife had a suggestion.
This is amazing.
I heard your wife had a suggestion
- I think I know where you're going.
- after finishing the book.
she read the book.
And what was the suggestion?
Tell everyone.
- It was the first, it was the end.
It was the, it was the last chapter.
And she looks at me and she says,
"Baby, this is really, really good.
But I think you need
to read your own book."
- Oh my God, that's a real talk.
(Kelly and audience chuckles)
- And the thing is, is it's true.
And I wrote this book, not as an expert
but as somebody who is in it,
I'm in the fire.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm under construction.
- That's the point.
And, and she reminded me that I'm like
I need to go back and
reread a lot of the chapters
especially the chapters where
I'm reminding other people
that they are enough.
You are enough because I struggle
with my enoughness every single day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I put
on my armor and I'm not
allowed to express it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But boy is it liberating
to be able to say like
"Oh my God, I'm a nervous being
on the Kelly Clarkson show,
this is awesome."
Because it makes us human
and we can have a real connection.
- Yeah, and what you're
talking about is it's not
only progressing you,
but it's progressing
society's way of thinking.
And then that's progressing
the whole world.
I think that's a really great
conversation to be done.
- But these aren't new ideas, as you know
- No, I know, but none of the.
- These are super old ideas and honestly,
women have been talking
about this stuff forever.
I'm just like, I'm just a
straight white privileged dude.
That's talking about it.
- I know but like, feel like
it's that thing, like when you
if you haven't gone to
church, I grew up in church
like growing up in church and it was like
every Sunday I was like,
is he talking to me?
Like the pastor, like the message.
I was like, wait, or if I hadn't been
in a while and I'd come
and I'd be like, Oh.
- Camera zooms in just on you.
- I'm like, I'm like, I'm like,
he knows I haven't been here.
This is about me.
Like I'm like, and so
I start to freak out.
But I think it's that
logical thing that would be
reminded things that you do know innately
but we just don't practice on
the daily because we get lost
and how busy we are and,
Oh, this is how it goes.
It's okay.
This is how I was taught.
- Yeah.
- And you don't, we don't progress.
I think it's really important.
I think this is awesome.
- Oh.
- So everybody, Justin's book is called
"Man Enough Undefining my
Masculinity" it's out now.
You gotta check it out.